não é futebol fã em
não precisa fazer fila que não é futebol
ae
em maio de 2013
eu estava trabalhando no alasca trabalha
como instrutor de esportes e aventura
trabalha como instrutor e canoagem
envie essa baleia baleia jubarte 50
metros no bairro
a bola subiu duas vezes perto do meu
barco por isso que eu tô desse jeito né
duas baleias ea minha casa branca não
pela baleia mas pelo protetor solar era
para reinar só trabalha com o
montanhismo também um caminho da
montanha e esse meu trabalho desde 2008
e deixa longe do brasil por oito a nove
meses por ano desde 2008 que eu fico
longe do meu estado eu sou uma pessoa
com muito orgulho
sou paraibano e sempre tive vontade de
fazer um projeto muito grande uma
expedição muito grande como essas que eu
tenho feito essa escola que chamou nesse
dia quando eu vi essa baleia
pra mim foi o meu everest não precisava
mais chegar ao topo de uma montanha mais
das montanhas que já tinha escalado
nessa noite eu falei pra ele voltar para
o estado voltar à paraíba fazer algo
grande
fazer uma expedição um projeto grande
nessa noite eu for matei o projeto
sangue de nossas veias cujo objetivo foi
percorrer a paraíba d oeste a westin
passando por uma rota essa rota que está
escrita a slide uma rota lógica mais uma
rota passando pelos principais centros
regionais e que dessa vez eu não ia
fazer por mim eu queria fazer pelos
outros
eu convidei o único ser humano que seria
capaz de acompanhar de me acompanhar
eu sabia que não ia ter condições de
organizar toda a logística do projeto
sozinho eu convidei o único ser humano
que na na época eu conheci que é capaz
que era capaz de também nesse projeto
comigo foi andré cena juntos a gente
formatou o projeto sangue nossas veias
que escolheu
aumentar a capacidade e doadores e
aumentar a capacidade de pessoas doando
sangue ou aumentar essa capacidade de
pelo menos as pessoas acordarem para a
questão do sangue na paraíba
e nós também escolhemos as crianças com
câncer e escolhemos a associação donos
do amanhã para arrecadar fundos para
eles então nosso objetivo era fazer esse
e se todo esse trajeto pedalando
chamando a atenção para essas duas
causas ao invés de apenas montar uma
expedição e cruzar paraíba d oeste e
oeste oeste
bom gente tirando esse comentário do ad
que eu seria um ser humano capaz de
realizar esse projeto
o resto é tudo verdade está porque todos
vocês são capazes de realizar qualquer
viagem não precisa ser super atleta não
precisa ser um homem não precisa ter um
um preparo físico excepcional para fazer
basta querer e ter vontade de fazer um
pouco de altruísmo não faz mal a ninguém
bom depois de nove meses planejando
contratando pessoas é fazendo contatos
captando recursos recebendo vários nãos
o que me dava mais incentivo que nos
dava mais incentivo ainda para continuar
né porque a gente sabia que estava no
caminho certo
depois de nove meses nós saímos foi
quase o tempo de uma gestação e até
comparou isso como a gestação nove meses
planejando para depois o filho nascer
bom
saímos no dia 4 de abril de 2014 de um
ponto entre a divisa do nosso estado da
paraíba estado do ceará localizado na br
esse primeiro dia para muito simples de
fazer e teoricamente sim nós estava no
rio na região do sertão e temos 85
quilômetros para cumprir até chegar na
primeira cidade nós iríamos realizar a
primeira palestra
só que logo nos primeiros 15 minutos nós
tivemos a primeira surpresa nós
saberíamos que temos um problema é claro
e evidente como
estou vendo aí um caminhão um treminhão
passando bem próximo de nós mesmos
falando no acostamento e nós estávamos
expostos a um risco que a gente não
controlava que é o trânsito
mesmo assim nós temos algumas atitudes
de segurança e seguimos viagem não foi
nada fácil
começamos o pedal pela vida dos outros
tentando pedra lá por nossas vidas
o pedal continua e daí nós chegamos em
sousa ainda já tinha que já havia caído
à noite e chegamos já com as lanternas
ligadas e fomos recebidos pela pela pelo
pelo clube de de bike local o que acabou
fazendo uma recepção bastante calorosa
mas nesse primeiro dia nos deu um
parâmetro muito grande nós teríamos nós
avaliamos o risco de continuar na
estrada a exposição que estávamos na
estrada durante os próximos vinte e três
dias que a vi que era o tempo geral da
viagem mas é em contrapartida manter o
clima positivo de interação com as
pessoas dos lugares que a gente ia
passar e que faziam parte do roteiro era
um ponto crucial para nós porque nós
dependemos das pessoas para poder ter um
resultado final do projeto então é uma
coisa que a gente tinha que a medida que
pedalava mas trabalhar e fazer um
trabalho de divulgação e catar e ao
mesmo tempo cativando as pessoas
junto com esse clube visitam vai alguns
pontos na região de sousa e vale dos
dinossauros e depois vai do dinossauro
nós continuamos e como toda a história é
a nossa história não é diferente
existem vários personagens da nossa
história né e o pedro ele é um deles
bom mas como é que o pedro entra nessa
história ou entra no projeto nós de
depois que saímos de souza caminhamos
rapidamente para uma confraternização
rápida com o pessoal do clube local e lá
combinamos um comboio onde nós iríamos
parte eles iriam nos acompanhar até a
próxima cidade eles nos acompanharam até
cerca de 80 quilômetros depois
retornaram para a cidade de origem e nós
continuamos numa estrada de terra o que
pra nós é bom
nós não teríamos o risco do trânsito mas
que em contrapartida nós estávamos
expostos a mais problemas com as
bicicletas e como a estrada era uma
estrada é pouco trafegado e pouco é
habitada para nós resolvemos o problema
nas bikes no a nu a nossa situação de
quebra foi o pneu seria mais difícil
alguns furos nos pneus aconteceram e
mais e mais e mais até o ponto que nós
ficamos sem câmaras de ar para reposição
né
então tomamos uma uma atitude de alterar
um pouco a rota do projeto se deslocar
até a uma cidade próxima ao local onde
estávamos e daí quando chegamos a
encontrar no peru que o peru já tenha
sido isso militar esse cabo do exército
tenha sido professor de biologia e
escola municipal já tenha sido assessor
do prefeito e estava estudando pra fazer
direito
e daí aparece o peru na nossa frente
como em uma figura de borracheiro
pressionar o nosso problema e daí nós
podemos continuar a viagem
então o peru tem uma parcela de
contribuição porque precisamos dele e
ele nos deu todo apoio e gratuitamente
quando nós explicamos passamos cerca de
duas horas dentro da rocha do peru
explicamos a ele que era o projeto e
falou se de um projecto conquistar o
objetivo de vocês e se precisar de ajuda
estou aqui e da estrada ainda
continuamos a viagem só que já existe em
vários outros personagens que eu vou
estar um pouco mais à frente e pedro
colocou dentro do ônibus quanto à minha
escola tinha furado o pneu três vezes é
difícil ter algum 11 carros enfim seguir
a etapa na minha cidade do meu pai lá eu
sabia que eu tinha um primo que eu não
via desde 89
aí eu não tenho nenhum contato com ele o
bug clube local a organizar um passeio
conosco nem no final da tarde não tinha
parado de lyon não tinha nenhum
deslocamento a fazer e de repente pode
ser ciclista do meu lado estava subindo
essa essa montanha que tem um estado
enquanto ela cantava o cristo redentor
na cidade
esse cristo apareceu do meu lado e
começou a pedalar e falou de um prêmio
chamado de nilson
aí falei qual o sobrenome dele falou
fonseca
eu falei com a qual o nome aí falou
adailton salvatore período era meu primo
era meu primo e que eu não via desde 39
quer dizer é manter um projeto para
ajudar pessoas e estava sendo ajudado
então eu entender saiu saiu seca de de
itaporanga seguinte pra piancó e lá é
existe um grupo escoteiro um grupo
escoteiros que é bem ativo e eu conheci
andré é pelo movimento escoteiro preciso
inteligência eo grupo decepcionou
eles organizaram a recepção muito bacana
onde tinha polícia tinha o samu
o pessoal do bairro esperando a gente na
entrada e tinha também o carro do lixo a
gente fez a segunda palestra terceira
palestra em um copo cheio de escuteiros
vão falar isso é muito bacana de lages
seguir o papa
depois da palestra lá o movimento
escoteiro que foi realizado na câmara
câmara municipal da cidade
nós seguimos que o objetivo agora
seguirá patos a nós saímos de de piancó
bem cedo antes do sol clarear e daí
tomamos o a estrada pra bater
tecnicamente um plano com poucas
elevações
mas a idéia foi chegar ainda de dia
claro
bom depois de 30 quilômetros que nós
paramos pra nos retratar repô comer um
pouco quando voltamos para as bicicletas
o pneu da bike indoor estava furado mais
uma vez de novo de novo quando
consertamos rapidamente e daí chega um
jovem tímido na direção da área todos
simples uma pessoa simples e que morava
há 15 quilômetros antes que nós temos
passado pela estada dele aquela casa
dele à beira da estrada e daí começou
muito curioso como todo o adolescente é
muito curioso começou a perguntar portas
bates maneiras toda colorida toda
equipada e de repente ele disse nós
terminamos o o o concerto seguimos
viagem
e ele diz reparei que o hotel levou até
aqui com vocês e daí nós olhamos um para
o outro né ele está ok vamos lá e daí o
pedro o sebastião que é um outro
personagem que surgiu nesse projeto a
ele não seguiu quando chegou dez
quilômetros eu olhei para o edson falou
pô
a gente tem que convencer a voltar né e
daí
ele não sabe não tem que voltar falou eu
vou até um pouco mais e daí até um pouco
mais ele surgiu a professora sueli na
sua proposta de comprar bike do ele
conhece toback maneira eu quero comprar
ela paga no cartão é de dirceu não
trouxe maquineta mas eu pague dinheiro
não mas eu tenho que continuar a viagem
e daí surge esse clima e resolvemos
parar 20 quilômetros 10 quilômetros mas
à frente totalizando 20 quilômetros de
onde tinha saído e convencemos ele vai
voltar
então pegamos algumas notas uma de
nossas garrafas de água temos pra ele há
alimento também passamos pra ele pra
ajudar um pouco na volta porque já
passava da do meio dia ele tenha saído
da escola pra voltar pra casa e
encontrou conosco no caminho então para
evitar qualquer transtorno acontecesse
com ele está a gostar alimento volta
para casa e daí nós seguimos viagem e é
com a proposta de chegar em patos de
ácaro então o sebastião ele teve uma uma
importância para nós porque foi mais uma
pessoa tá aí a imagem de sebastião é pra
vocês time da lei a garrafinha de água
que nós passamos para ele uma crise com
assinada por nós e que o nome dele além
com a dedicatória baccan e daí ele
começou a contar a vida dele pra nós e
foi e também comentando que ele tenha
pessoas na família que já tenha falecido
com câncer e daí acabou que ele ficou
ali marcado na história porque quando
ele quando a gente se despedir dele e
lhe deu uma mensagem pra gente dizendo
sigam o projeto eu tô torcendo por vocês
aqui não tenho nada como como ajudar mas
fico na torcida para poder é que vocês
conquistar esse objetivo
seguimos para uma cidade chamada patos e
lá o projeto ficou claro pra gente que
tá tomando uma proporção muito grande
causando a mídia espontânea muito muito
grande
sites rádios e tvs de internet então
naquela hora eu vi que o que o projeto
estava atingindo a o seu objetivo que
era é causar a curiosidade das pessoas
em se tornarem doadores de sangue e
ajudar crianças com câncer e seu se eu
entro talvez tivéssemos ido de carro a
gente não teria causado esse impacto se
a gente tivesse passado só por lá só de
bicicleta sem ter uma causa também não
teria feito o mesmo impacto que lá a
gente seguiu pra cá a cidade de taperoá
num dia muito um dia muito difícil já
que a gente falou mais foi foram 98 92
quilômetros cópias completas carregadas
com mais 25 quilos a mais ea gente vê
uma paraíba muito bacana uma paraíba que
a gente nunca tinha passado por lá na
paraíba verde é extremamente diferente
extremamente bonita só foi um dia muito
difícil e foi um dia que eu que eu eu
lembrei lucas de la gente seguiu para a
cidade de taperoá e esse dia esse dia de
taperoá até a cidade do sul é foi um dia
bastante diferentes um único dia que nós
pedalamos inteiro em estrada de chão e o
nosso isolamento estava claro nesse dia
apenas três carros três carros passaram
por nós nesse dia foi um dia um dia
muito bacana um também uma paraíba muito
muito bacana e foi um dia muito quente
mais uma vez um dia muito difícil com
muita subida muita madeira de novo as
bicicletas carregadas e de novo veio a
imagem a imagem de lucas na nossa cabeça
de lá ele seguiu para monteiro nós
chegamos em monteiro pouco antes do
horário do almoço e como não era
diferente
como não foi diferente nós seguimos
diretamente para a rádio local da cidade
para poder divulgar a o projeto
convidando toda a população local
para participar da palestra que
ocorreria no dia seguinte e assim foi
monteiro foi a única cidade do projeto
que recebeu duas edições da nossa
palestra é tratando sobre a doação
espontânea de sangue é como ajudar
crianças com câncer
a alimentação saudável e prática de
atividade esportiva
só que em monteiro aconteceu um caso
visitado foi lá é onde nós tivemos a
oportunidade de conhecer uma pessoa que
estava retornando da capital estava
vindo trata aí tava voltava vindo veio
para a capital tratar se tratar fazer
uma sessão de quimio e etapa retornando
pra cidade para monteiro por não ter
conseguido realizar o tratamento aqui
houve uma falta de comunicação do
hospital com ela o hospital teria visto
tecnicamente ligou pra ela pra avisar
que ela não precisaria aí pra vir para a
cidade
e daí houve essa falha de comunicação
ela veio e retornou sem fazer o
tratamento então foi daí que me caiu a
ficha de putz
se isso acontece com adultos
imagina o sofrimento de crianças que vêm
para a capital vinda do interior do
estado e crianças pobres e que chegam
aqui não tem uma estrutura para passar a
noite né não tem uma estrutura de
alimentação e precisa às vezes retornar
é com esse diz tendo esse desgaste
tendo esse esse é a já com a imunidade
já baixa é então imagine você eu fiquei
muito sensibilizado e daí eu mais uma
vez nós chegamos à conclusão de que o
caminho é esse que esse era o que nós
estamos no caminho certo de monteiro nós
saímos taí uma imagem na rádio local de
monteiro nós saímos para a próxima
cidade fazendo a aaa seguindo o primeiro
pedal noturno do projeto e daí foi muito
bacana foi o primeiro pedaço do projeto
que nós fizemos com a experiência de
passar pela rua das moças que tem na
região do cariri
o projeto continuou e teve e se essa
rota
passamos por várias outras cidades como
bananeiras araruna é campina grande e
chegamos chegamos a joão pessoa no dia
26 de abril dia 26 de abril a gente foi
recebido pelos nossos amigos e nós dois
mas um monte de amigos nós fomos direto
para o hemocentro para doar sangue e
muitas muitas pessoas foram
e a gente conseguiu uma arrecadação
muito bacana que vocês vão ver daqui a
pouco resultado certamente ambos
aprendemos com esse projeto é e
aprendemos também é importante ter
realizado um bom trabalho e há hipótese
de ter de estar ali
em certos momentos
vocês ter a sensação nós temos a
sensação de ajudar outros a sonharem
e vocês também precisam ter essa
sensação vocês precisam sentir isso
realmente de arrepiar
vocês precisam praticar mais isso
embarquei num sonho desse cara e fiz
pelo meu sonho inspira pessoas foram 23
dias 1.150 quilômetros 23 cidades nove
palestras 40 litros de sangue
oito mil seiscentos e quarenta e quatro
reais doados arrecadados e um lucas
lucas foi uma criança que a gente
conheceu na associação
nesse dia e andré gente vai fazer uma
reunião para fechar parceria com a
associação e eu me preparei para andré a
gente vai ver criança sabe as condições
que nós iríamos ver essas crianças mas
entramos na sala do diretor e quando a
gente saiu tem essa imagem de de uma
criança com uma perna e as muletas e nós
fomos apresentados a lucas pela ea mãe
dele também e há uma diretora falou
esses meninos vão pedalar pela paraíba e
vão ajudar vocês e daí nunca olhou e
falou se eu tivesse duas pernas eu ia
com vocês
obrigado